as soon as you find somebody who says to
you if you contradict me you're not
Contracting a man you're Contracting
signs itself well that that person you
shouldn't be trusting
in a complicated situation like this you
need a very very wide array of voices
some of whom are going to disagree with
each other
uh I if I were in charge of the uh
messaging and decision making around at
the CDC or at the NIH or elsewhere what
I would have done is I would Embrace
that fact and treated the American
public like adults would have injected
more trust and we would have gotten
better results where you know than we
did which is essentially by saying look
uh Tony fauci's view is the only view
that matters everyone else's
misinformation that by itself I think is
responsible for a tremendous amount of
the damage that happened during the
pandemic